democracy in the united states
lived through one of the
darkest chapters in its history on january 6,
president by the end and
vice president harris must contribute
to creating a climate of harmony that heals
the wounds of division and
polarization rejection  abroad,
racism, aversion to women,
anti-Semitism, denial of
climate change or anti-vaccine activism
represent the delusions of an extreme
right that is increasingly present in
Western democracies together with this
liberal ideology that advocates
fear of being different, let's not forget  that the
growth of inequalities,
tax evasion, deindustrialization
and high unemployment have
of course also contributed to the fact that millions of
people in the usa and in the european union
have lost faith in democracy the
horrible scenes from the capitol also
show that we have to fight  more
effectively against disinformation and
guarantee the
right of citizens  help us to receive
truthful information the digital services law
proposed by the commission should serve
to regulate the removal of
illegal content from online platforms with
full respect for freedom of expression
another challenge shared with the
baiden and harris administration is the
reconstruction of a
multilateral system that guarantees respect
for democratic norms and institutions
on both shores of the atlantic
we have to learn that democracies
are built every day and let us not forget
what the second president of the united states
john adams had in mind when he
founded his country freedom  once lost
it is lost forever in our hands
is to preserve it